all of that stuff prevents us from being
at our best
we can only be truly great at what we do
if we believe without doubt that
my guest today is an 11 time european
world champion in her field
anna hemmings she has a remarkable story
not only is she this
incredible elite athlete not only did
she get to the olympics twice
but she's undergone some of the most
incredible mind-bending adversity to get
there
she's now a coach she's now an
entrepreneur she's now an incredible
businesswoman
and she has a remarkable story to tell
you she's also a mother
and a wife and all of these things and
she's
she's
really incredibly self-analystical and
self-aware and as her journey unfolded
and as she rose to the top of her career
she got news which all athletes must
consider to be the worst
news in the world i'm so excited for you
to listen to this conversation
you're going to get a tremendous amount
of value and i'll be honest
as a host you ask the questions but in
this conversation i had more
realizations than
pretty much any conversation i've had
with a guest before without further ado
you can see i'm excited my name is
stephen bartlett and this is the diver
ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
kayaking it's um it's not
this the type of sport that
a child would typically dream of getting
into so i guess my first question to you
is you became
a world champion in kayaking you reached
the very sort of peak of your
your your career in that sport how did
you get into kayaking
yeah you're absolutely right it wasn't
something i was going mom mom please
don't be kayaking
um i did lots of different sports as a
child
and i loved sport my mum was always
trying to get my brother and i partly
because we enjoyed sport but
sometimes just you know summer holidays
going to a week of tennis camp do a week
of basketball week of this
and it was just something that we tried
i loved being on the river you know
the thames in the summer is gorgeous
right you know it's pretty miserable
right now
um but in the summer it's lovely but
also the club was competitive
it was it was elm bridge canoe club and
it was
probably one of the best clubs in the
country at the time so this is
late 80s and
and they were all about racing they were
all about competing they were all about
you know working your way up to the
national championships getting on the
great britain team going to the world
championships making the olympics that
was their mission it was to produce
racing athletes and that played
into my competitive nature really well
so i think it was
one i love the you know the nature of
the sport but also i'd
stumbled on a place where i could be
competitive i could race i could
um i had access to these brilliant
coaches i mean as time went on
i was there with at my club there were
people who were going off
to the olympic games who were going off
to seoul um
olympic games then four years later they
going off to barcelona and
so i was surrounded by people who were
going to world championships achieving
great things
and making me realize that actually
this is this is possible so i've got two
questions there
the first is what age were you at this
point so well when i first stepped into
the kayak that first summer i was
just under nine years old and and i
can't say that at that age i was going
by
first day in the kayak i'm going to go
to olympics it wasn't that and it
probably wasn't until the following
summer that i actually
really started to train and
go regularly and really get into it so
you you said there as well about
you were surrounded by people that had
these big ambitions that i'm guessing
you probably never
even considered and i think for i think
that's such a
valuable but also interesting lesson
about like the company people keep
generally because
i can imagine that if you were in a
different kayak school
surrounded by different people that
didn't have that level of aspiration
you may be and this is a presumption you
maybe wouldn't have
believed that it was possible for you is
that right
um so i yes i agree
um i also
had discovered the olympics probably
around that time and
was inspired by the olympics and i do
recall from that young age
thinking just the olympics is just this
amazing
event so i think really early on i
had a dream about the olympics um and i
didn't know what sport that would be i
you said you had a dream did you see
yourself actually getting there
in a sport someday yes really yeah i did
i
i did watch the olympics on television
um
i recall los angeles i definitely recall
watching
um seoul and really being into that so
well you know by seoul i'm like 12 years
old i guess
um watching thinking i want to be
an olympian i want to be in that event
one day and then
and then kayaking came along and
and you're right it because of those
people
it didn't feel like because i guess
probably when you're watching it on tv
it's like oh this is this thing that
other people do
and it's far away and how do you ever
yes we'd all love to be in the olympics
moment not everyone but
you know but how realistic is that and
then i stumble upon this sport
and this club and these young
athletes are going turning up training
they're just like normal people to me
but if they can do it and these normal
people who just work really hard
can get there then why can't i i'm so
fascinated by it and you probably
saw me being very inquisitive because
i'm in my head i'm trying to understand
how
um what the factors were that came
together that took you to the olympics
and
like i think in all of our journeys we
can um
we can attribute some level of like
coincidence and luck to various stages
and i think one of the
moments of like luck from what you've
said is like
being around the right people to some
degree because
um yeah i've just i think especially
lately in my life i've really been able
to look back and say you know what if i
if i hung around with a different group
of people if i didn't have you know mum
that was like this or
i didn't have those five friends um i
probably wouldn't have
uh believed that like that as you i find
it really interesting you say the word
normal people
because i think we all view ourselves
especially when we're younger it's like
normal people
and we think that norm when you look at
the tv as you say like you don't think
normal people can do that stuff on there
and at some point someone like bridged
the gap and was like oh by the way
normal people do that
and i think that's a moment that i had
in my life which i found really
interesting from what you've described
there
there's like the thing where the like
the third wall shatters and you realize
that
all of your icons and like you know the
people you love are also just like
we're just like you yeah i think that's
super um
inspiring so we've talked a little bit
about circumstance and like
the the luck fortune part of it and
being in the right place at the right
time but
also within everybody's journey there is
a lot of
intention there's a lot of like often
discipline i imagine
what what are the things about you that
maybe the few defining things that maybe
other people
don't don't have i always have to be
careful with this question because no
one wants to blow their own trumpet
but i'm like why you like why are you
not someone else we've talked about
circumstance
but what are the things that you within
your character
got you there versus everyone else who
might have quit or not tried as hard it
wasn't as competitive or whatever
that's difficult um i definitely worked
hard
um and lots of people work hard right
and i worked really really hard and i
think
i think one thing that made me even more
determined
was that so as i mentioned already when
people see a
think of a kayaker they often think of
someone quite tall yeah they often think
of aurora
right and and they're different sports
but most people think roar
and they think super tall big and and i
am a little bit small
um not typically the typical size for a
kayaker so
generally a little bit taller um broader
shoulder
i'm five six six um and
i was i was told regularly too small um
one of my coach actually um the club
coach he was also the great britain team
coach came up to me at a certain point
um when i was really into the sport and
said
i just don't think you're ever going to
be big enough or strong enough to ever
be a great kayaker
knowing that i was really wanting to be
a great kayaker
and but also knowing that i did some
other sports and was kind of going
maybe you should go and do those because
i know you i just don't want you to
um put all your heart into this and not
succeed how did that feel
devastating right this is the sport that
i'm falling and
fallen in love with um that i'm this is
probably i'm about 12 years old so at
this stage i am
training quite regularly i've already
been to the national championships i've
got my sights set on being in the great
britain junior team
devastating but i think because of that
i
i just went well i'm just going to keep
going i'm going to keep trying i don't
care what you've said i don't care
you know this is what i want to do um
i'm going to give it a go and i love it
and i think i'm doing okay at it right
now
and i'm just gonna keep trying what that
did
for me was made me
made me work harder to prove that
actually
because i was told specifically you're
not big enough you're not strong enough
and yeah i can't change my height but i
can become stronger
and when i was at the peak of my career
i was the strongest
girl in the gym in the great britain
team
i've got to admit i saw the photos i was
bench pressing 100 kilos yeah you were
strong and so and i i was determined
that
no one's going to tell me i'm not strong
enough because i i can't change how tall
i am but i can change how strong i am
why did it matter though why did it
matter to be successful to you at this
good question because a lot of i think
about that moment where someone tells
you
you're going to fail whatever we've all
had that moment i think every successful
person's had that moment
and people typically google one of two
ways they'll either go forget this then
you know chuck it in or whatever um or
they'll have the adverse effect i almost
don't know anybody that sits in the
middle you either get really in
you get some kind of insecurity which
takes you either one way which either
means that i'm going to triple down and
become obsessive or i'm
gonna avoid um avoid this at all costs
and i tend i tend to think that people
who this really really really
intrinsically matters to
for whatever reason are the ones that go
the positive way and use it as
motivation
yeah definitely i'm i loved winning um
why i love the i love the joy
of i loved i i loved winning but i also
loved improvement and i loved
it getting better quite often i was told
so they're in kayaking there's singles
doubles fours k1 k2 k4
and i was always told
you know not big enough not strong
enough but also
definitely not big enough or strong
enough to be in a k4
definitely not big enough to be in any
of the crew boats k2 k4 you need to be
big and strong for those boats
and i probably shouldn't say this but
they they used to
it felt to me defined big and strong
as fat and
if you were so i was skin and bones i
was really skinny
and so i didn't look strong but they
thought someone who looked
chunky had a big backside
was strong okay and i'm like no that
that just because they're big
doesn't mean they're going to be faster
than they're going to be more valuable
in that boat than me
so do you think you're like
underestimated unfairly yeah i do
and and that so winning world
championships in a k2 getting to olympic
games in a doubles
was very satisfying for me um
whenever i was able to prove that
actually you don't have to be
what you're describing as this kind of
shape
um that's not what makes someone fast
and useful in a kayak in a double kayak
or in a four
so that used to annoy me i saw you talk
about uh
one of the things mentioned when i was
doing a little bit of research on you is
this idea of like healthy conflict
in teams could you explain because i've
never heard of the term
i could imagine i could guess what it
means but i'd love you to explain what
healthy con conflict is in
terms of teams and so in a
team um it starts with trust
if we don't have trust in a team then we
can't have healthy conflict and healthy
conflict is when we
healthy debate so this is about being
able to
know that all of the people in the team
have the same objective the same
um we're all gonna got the same goal
we're trying to achieve the same thing
and you put forward an idea and you and
and i
i disagree with that idea but if we
don't have trust in the team
and you're the boss then i'm not going
to put my hand up and say
i disagree i don't think we should do it
like that i think we should do it like
this
i think that this is the way we should
go i think we need to go down this route
we won't have that argument and an
argument debate
conflict whatever you want to call it if
there's not enough trust in the team
if you think that you're going to be
shot down if you think you're not going
to be listened to
um and then the problem with that is
that
we then walk out of the room and you've
probably been in meetings right where
people all
sit in the room and they all nod and go
yeah brilliant yeah we're all going to
do that and then they walk out of the
room and they go
you got another thing coming you think
i'm going to do that and they do that
because they haven't had their say
they haven't been able to disagree and
and back and forth with their ideas
and have that debate even if your idea
isn't gone with
they at least want to feel like i've had
my say
and i've had my opportunity to put
forward my thoughts and my opinion and
my suggestion
but actually at the end of the day this
is the best idea for the team
then fine let's go with that but at
least i've had my opportunity to speak
up
and you talk about you know that sounds
very sort of analogous to like
relationships as well
because i think you know like romantic
relationships right people get a little
bit
peeved if they don't feel like they're
being heard and had a chance to express
themselves and also when they have that
when they do express themselves quite
often it's perceived as
in the name of being right or winning
versus in the name of like progress or
solving the problem it's like me and you
versus
each other versus mean universe is the
problem right yeah
how do you build the trust foundation
they're like what's the how do you get a
team to trust each other and whatever
because if that's the foundation of
healthy conflict i'm like how do i you
know what can i do to so
one of the things that that you can do
and this is why you know i work with
teams and leaders
and it's about vulnerability it's about
being um able to be vulnerable with your
people with your team
um being able to admit weaknesses admit
mistakes
um it's about being able to say i i
don't know the answer
i don't know where we're going well i
don't know what i don't you know i don't
know
how to deal with this or i you know just
being able to be
vulnerable and and that isn't always
easy to do
but when you start to do it it gives
permission
to people you know if you we do
workshops where we're trying to build
trust
and people always say you know at the
end we might ask them something like um
share something about challenge from
your childhood
and when we when people go around and
they share and we say
what what made it difficult or hard to
do and they say well it made it easier
when someone else went first
because once you've opened up and you've
bared yourself a little bit
then i feel oh well he's done it then
it's okay and no one judged him
and and no one knocked him and and it's
like okay well i can do it too
and knowing that no one's and
when there is that trust then we know
that actually i'm not going to be
that's not going to be held against me
whatever it is that i share
it's not going to be hard against me in
the future it's not going to be
um used and i'm not going to be shot
down for it
you a lot of this is like about the
psychology of how people think and
operate and i know that you spent some
time working with a psychologist or a
sports psychologist when you were
rising in your career um i find that
super fascinating
but i'd love to know what some of the
key sort of lessons you learned about
high performance or about
i guess like self-regulation um from
that
that psychologist as it relates to
becoming a world champion and
you know yeah yeah um yeah so i did i
worked with a sports psychologist for
from the age of 16. oh really yeah so
really young and
and i think that um
was part of and you talk about um you
know you asked me earlier what is it
that
made me a little bit different or why
did i succeed when others didn't and i
think
part of that was um
have you heard of growth mindset yes
yeah yeah so i think that my
i didn't know about that then and
neither did you know a lot of people but
my mom um was pretty
quite growth mindset and and i and
instilled that quite a lot in me
for example she you know this idea of
just constant learning constantly
wanting to
learn and be better and recognizing that
we can be better all the time we can
improve
um and looking outside for other
areas of expertise learning from other
sectors and all of that
and she was the one that you know it
wasn't like i was struggling with my
mental strength and confidence or
anything
it was just what else do we need to do
what who else can help us who else can
what
you know we don't have all the answers
we want to learn we've got to learn from
everyone and i always encourage
clients in the business world you know
who who can we constantly
be learning from all the time what was
the what are they like some of the
key things yeah and also what i think
what are they trying to do i i guess
they're trying to make you the best
athlete you can be
but what are the things stopping you
from being the best athlete you can be
ourselves yeah exactly most of the time
we are the ones that get in our own way
how how do we get in our own way the
doubts the
the thing the thoughts that we think um
the doubt that that seeds um the nerves
overcoming us so so becoming so nervous
that you
become paralyzed almost um choking
under pressure focusing on the wrong
things not being confident in yourself
um yeah so many things that we do
fear doubt is a really interesting one
there's fears doubt
anxiety nerves lack of confidence all of
that stuff
prevents us from being at our best and
that essentially is
what was one of the one of the big parts
of what a sports psychologist is helping
you to do
when an athlete when you line up and
there's nine of you on the start line at
the olympic games
all of them all of those athletes were
trained hard they're all in amazing
shape they're all super fit they're all
you know strong they're you know
physically there's
not a huge amount of difference between
those nine you know i think about 100
meter sprint
at the olympic games there's not a lot
of difference between them
what is it that makes one of them win on
the day and not often it's often not
the strongest fastest fittest who wins
on the day
it's the one who's the strongest up here
and i really believe that
that this is often what stops people
from fulfilling their potential
and that's why i love helping people
with noun yeah yeah absolutely
their mental game is what stops people
from being the best they can be
of all the things that we do in our
minds you talked about fear doubt
anxieties all these kinds of things
fear and doubt like lack of self belief
not believing that you can or
all those things that's probably one of
the most common sort of mental games
that um
holds us back or um limits us from our
full potential
um how does how does one go about
overcoming their own limiting beliefs
about themselves like they think okay
well no i can't do that
everybody thinks they can't do
everything it seems these days like i
don't know why maybe it's just because
of what i do for a living but
um i'm just surrounded by an audience of
people that have real limiting beliefs
and i wonder why but i also wonder how
you help them overcome their limiting
beliefs big question
it's a huge question how do we overcome
our limiting beliefs it's actually
something that i work on a lot with
when i'm coaching clients um
identifying beliefs that uh so you know
we would start probably with what are
some of those limiting beliefs
and start to unpick how are those
beliefs where
how are they serving i wouldn't be
interested in necessarily where they've
come from
i would be interested in how are they
serving us right now and how are they
not serving us because
sometimes there's we're believing them
because they're serving us for a purpose
they're helping us in some way but often
more often than not those beliefs won't
be serving us
um so starting to unpick that um
you know almost like what are the pros
and cons of having this belief here
um right now that i can't achieve this
or that
one of my limiting beliefs was that i'm
not very good at sales um you know i was
i had to i have to you know i run a
training consultancy i have to
you know find clients and um how you
know
so what's a more helpful belief um and
starting to one pick
what would be a better way of seeing
this what are my strengths
and what would be a new belief that
would be serve me better
i think at some point in your journey
you probably not at one particular
moment but gradually i imagine you
started to build evidence
within yourself that you could be a
great kayaker
and i imagine that was over a long
period of time probably there wasn't one
day where you woke up and thought [ __ ]
i'm good right yeah exactly and i think
um that is a big part of where we get
our confidence from is like our past
experiences yeah so whenever we do
something
we we start to build a bank of memories
and when we're at the next situation
that is similar we can choose to draw on
the bank of negative experiences where
we cocked it up
or we can choose to draw on the bank of
positive experiences where we succeeded
and we did it really well
and the trick is and you know if we if
we and if we're not conscious about it
chances are we might pick the experience
of when we failed
and then that's when we start to
regurgitate all those thoughts and
feelings of embarrassment and anxiety
and nerves and
and that doesn't help us and that's like
that probably would then
hinder performance absolutely it
perpetuates the
you know the doubt and the because
you're reminding yourself of all
remember last time when you did it you
cocked it up and you messed up and you
did it then you then [ __ ] it up because
you're thinking
and then you [ __ ] it up because and we
think in images yeah and so when you
think of something that you messed up
you're seeing yourself doing it right
you're imagining it in your mind right
here and now
and so the trick is to consciously
recall the positive experience the past
successes
and if there's nothing in the bank
exactly of that experience there's
chances are there's something similar
there's always something similar and you
know so i would work with clients to
identify
what are all of the successes that
you've had not just
in that specific scenario but let's
let's
look at lots of different successes and
then let's pick out
what are the what are the attributes
that allowed you to achieve those things
because
quite often someone will go oh well i
achieved that but
it was because the weather was good on
that day or i achieved that because my
team
my team did it really it wasn't me so
it's about starting to unpick
actually what role did you play in that
success and what
are the attributes that allowed you your
strengths your attributes that allowed
you to achieve that
and then we start to build up the bank
of successes
and the strengths and the attributes
which we can transfer into any scenario
how much do you think people
and this is i don't know why i'm asking
this question because it's not
quantifiable
but like to what extent do you p do you
think people underestimate their
potential generally
oh massively like would you say like
over 95
because i think i'd say over i think i'd
say people realize
what like typically the average person
realizes
about five percent of their potential
and i only real only say this because
again like you said i'm was very normal
kid from very my parents bankrupt like
we i dropped out i got kicked out of
school poor grades everything but this
one thing i had and i always say like
the one thing i had was i genuinely
believed
that i was gonna be where i am today
just for no
without a ton of evidence just generally
believed and in fact
the one of the reasons why i believed it
was but not because i had any bank of
successes yet
but i had a little bit but it was
actually contrasting
me to my peers when i was 14 and
thinking
i think that i have skills they don't
and i think that if these are the people
that become adults
then i will have i will always have that
advantage um so that was my way of like
and so when i
like cocked up my grades and gcse and
when school starts with that narrative
that okay well you got an e so you're
gonna
be in have an e life you're gonna be
broke and unhappy
like no you're wrong like um so i get my
mother
you were you were gathering evident you
were looking at your strengths
which is part of the puzzle right you
may not have had the
experiences and the evidence of the
achievements and the certificates and
all of that
but you what's more valuable is what you
had
is the non-tangible stuff yeah because
if we go through life
only assessing our success on the
tangible stuff
yeah then our confidence our self-belief
actually in their two different things
will be quite fragile oh yeah i can i
can see that because you're always
assessing yourself against
a trophy a trophy or society
because you're compared to oh i got this
award
against all of these other people and
and and i won this trophy and i went
past this grade and i
and it's always against somebody else
and a society rather than
looking at the intangible attributes
that allowed you to achieve those
successes because that's what
isn't measurable against society and is
transferable
to other domains and this is the and
you're completely right and i've never
actually thought about it that way
before
because i've always tried to figure out
why at 14 i was convinced that i would
be successful
and 18 i wrote my diary i'm going to
have a range of sport before that i'm 25
i'm gonna be a millionaire from 25
achieved all of those things
just knew i would but it was pure as you
said it was purely based on and it's
almost a strength audit or skills order
versus other people that i knew and i
thought oh those skills are really good
skills and they'll take you far but
school is about tangibles like and i'd
say a grade is a tangible yeah so
school says okay you got a an e so
unfortunately like it creates the
impression from all angles you're gonna
be poor
like and you're not going to be that
successful but timmy over there who's
got an a
he's really going to kill it as a
surgeon you know and and i think so how
you make it out
alive out of that system and still with
your you know self-esteem and
self-belief intact is
remarkable what i and i think that what
you had is is better than
the certificate yeah yeah because yeah
but but what it does is it allows you to
go
this is intrinsic in me no one can take
it
no one can take that away and my
self-worth isn't based on a certificate
and a trophy and an award how do you
give people that
well so you work on identifying those
strengths what are those strengths
we do this all the time we work with
clients on
what are those strengths and where's the
evidence of those strengths and when
they start to see the evidence of those
strengths well
you know so i'm i i'm working with a
client
and you know so one of your strengths is
being an authentic leader um one of your
strengths is
building relationships where's the
evidence of that look at all these
people
what do you do about weaknesses though
so would you highlight their weaknesses
i think it's important to highlight both
i think it's more important to
work on exploiting your strengths and
i would um so we do a lot of diagnostics
we use
behavioral profiling and all of that
kind of stuff and all of that will
bring up both and i think it's important
to really be aware of your
areas of development but ultimately
if i'm sat on the start line of the
world championships and i'm focused on
my weaknesses
and all the things i need to avoid my
confidence is fragile
yeah chances of performing on best slim
and so in that moment
i absolutely need to have on the tips of
my fingers what my strengths are
and i need to know them and i need to be
able to exploit them
and i think the more you work on those
the better
what do you think about this idea of
like labeling yourself in your line of
work and
the the broader labels we give ourselves
even if it's just like bad salesmen you
talked about that being one of your like
previous little limiting beliefs or
labels
um i think they're not helpful and i
think it's really important that we're
aware of those labels that we're giving
ourselves and
the awareness is the first step right we
can't change it if we don't notice it
so we need to notice the the label in
the first place and then
it's a bit you know it's like it's a
limiting belief really isn't it um
and so is that label serving me is it
helping me achieve my end goal
it feels like it sometimes because it's
making me fit in and it's giving me
comfort so
i see this a lot with people that will
say i am a
in my case i'm just gonna use my case
i'm a social media ceo
and i so i've been a social media ceo
for 10 years
it gives me some kind of like community
to be part of it gives me a sense of
identity
but at the same time it stops me from
being all that i can be
and this is one thing i was going over
in my book is like now i've left my
company
it's so tempting to just start another
social media business
but like there's so much more i can do
and so what
i'm asking this question cause i'm in
the midst of really thinking about it is
like
how do i just resist my labels and be
a [ __ ] dj i'm doing i'm doing this
big theatrical show and working in
biotech and um i don't know i just this
idea of like liberating yourself from
your own labels has been super
relevant to me um i think that
um it becomes your identity is a bigger
part of the problem
you know it's like when an athlete
retires from sport
it took me and it still takes me i catch
myself saying
you know i'm an athlete i'm not a
business person
and i go oh i um you know i don't have a
background in business
yeah i've been running a business for 11
years and i was a professional athlete
for 15 years so it's almost this
you know i have almost the same amount
of experience in business as i do in
in sport yeah i labeled myself for so
long and i be that became my identity
and your identity is ceo of a social
media company
and so that's who i am and it's hard
to let go of that because it's part of
who i am
yeah and it's comfortable right and you
know
you know who that person is what the
behavior of that person's like and
and you're stepping into a new role that
what does this new person look like how
rewarding has that been
for you to kind of i guess reinvent
yourself from being an athlete to now
being an entrepreneur
and a business person was it worth it
that's what i'm saying was it worth it
to step out of that label
yeah totally and and we should all have
multiple careers
um and i think as time you know as we're
living longer and longer we all will
have multiple careers and i think we
need to find the courage
to step into new careers all the time
and reinvent and
and just recognize that there's so many
skills that we can transfer
from that other career label identity
and bring into the next one and that's
what will allow us to succeed
into the next one and recognizing that
we're never going to grow
unless we step out of that comfort zone
and
yeah get a little bit scared of who this
new person
could be or would be or should be and
we'll find out
and that's the exciting thing is we're
going to find out how do you for some
people that's terrifying
yeah the thought of like throwing
themselves into that
place of uncertainty that they have to
travel through before they get to
their new self how do you get someone to
come willingly into uncertainty
to leave that job or to you know take on
that promotion or to
pivot in their career when they're
scared of
the unknown or you know it's like well
then i would think about what
i would think about rather than what i'm
afraid of i'm thinking about what i'm
excited about
and so rather than i'm afraid of what
i'm going to leave behind or i'm afraid
of
what might happen i'm more about what
could happen
and when we focus on what we want and
what we could have and you know it's a
it's optimism isn't it it's about what's
possible and what could i achieve
you know and you asked me earlier about
you know some of the things about
sports psychology and visualization was
one was a massive
technique really that i learned from my
sports psychologist and employed and
still use all the time
and i think when you can start to
visualize
what that new role person identity could
be
and when you bring it to life with all
of your senses
and see it really vividly then that's
exciting
and what what could i achieve and what
could this look like
and and the power of visualization is
that your mind
does when it's when you see it really
vividly your mind doesn't know the
difference between a vividly imagined
experience and a real life experience
what's your process for visualization
and now is it something that you do
actively you set time aside and do it or
is it just something that you
naturally now do when you're pursuing a
goal
so a little bit of both as an athlete it
was definitely something that i would
sit down usually i'd be lying on my bed
i would have done some relaxation
because the more we clear our mind and
relax the easier it is to visualize and
to see really clearly
and so i would it would be a conscious
right i'm gonna spend the next 15
minutes or even two minutes or five
minutes or whatever time i had
visualizing my next race
and seeing myself execute that race plan
as
perfectly as i can and in exactly the
right way and i would visualize
everything from
um if it was the olympic discipline and
we've got nine boats on a start line i'm
seeing my i don't know which lane i'm
gonna be in when it comes to race day so
i'm seeing myself racing every lane
i'm seeing myself with with the headwind
with a tailwind with it raining
i'm seeing myself [ __ ] up the start
because that might happen
but then i just going to recover from it
and i'm going to see myself recover and
i'm going to see myself win from behind
i'm going to see myself win from the
front
i'm going to see imagine you know
they'll start being delayed or it's a
full start you know all these
eventualities
so that when it comes to the event i'm
prepared
and it can just all unfold and i'm not
phased by anything that happens but but
most importantly
i've seen it happen the way i want it to
happen
and then i believe that it can happen
and what visualization also does is when
we
when we're visualizing a goal for
example
it starts to activate the subconscious
to generate creative ideas about how we
can achieve our goal
it's it's it's my i don't know how it
works and why it works but it's
mind-blowing and it does work and
and it starts to um get your brain to
perceive and recognize the different
um resources that you need
to achieve your goal it's like the law
of attraction
and it starts to activate that in your
life and
bring in the people the resources the
environment the circumstances that you
need
to achieve your goal and so now
what do i do i probably i do spend some
time
consciously going like i'm just going to
spend two or three minutes visualizing
my goal i'm seeing it happen
i'm seeing it realize um
but then other times i'm probably just
you know driving in my car and
subconsciously you know like daydreaming
almost but i think the
the conscious right i'm gonna visualize
now
is really powerful because then you
start to
really it starts to ingrain in the
subconscious
so the law of attraction stuff i think
sometimes it can take people one of two
ways because i do believe in
visualization
my visualizations over the years have
been very like the daydreaming stuff but
then also when i was like
really really really broke and living in
moscow in like a boarded up house
i would frequently look at stuff that in
the future i wanted
so i'd look at these like mansion houses
and whatever and that was me kind of
just
um setting my i don't know trying to
peer into my future life
the bit that i think sometimes gets lost
when we talk about like the law of
attraction
it's almost akin to like when you set
off in the morning
you put your satin have him and you say
this is where i want to go i want to go
test go
but then if you don't like put the key
in and put your foot down you're just
going to be sat in your garage
and but there's something about knowing
where you want to go
and as you say like almost programming
your brain to trick your brain to think
to completely be convinced that you will
get there
that i then that from my experience then
makes you take actions
in that direction so like i'm sure you
then
you visualize yourself as a world
champion but then you're like you go in
the gym
and you you train like a world champion
because you that's where you that's your
destination
and the the the the opposite is also
true like if you visualize yourself not
being world champion
what's the point you know you know um so
my
my real question here is about all of
the
actions and the discipline it takes
especially as an athlete
to get you from where you are to that
visualized destination
i'm really keen to hear about like the
discipline the consistency because
you're in a physical very very physical
endurance
race and you know it's like i think
muhammad ali said like
it's one in the gym it's one in training
a lot of it
and we all struggle with that we all
struggle with like showing up on
monday when it's raining so like what's
the
what's the key there so i think i think
you're absolutely right you know when we
visualize
it it gives us the motivation to believe
that it can happen yeah yeah and that's
that's at the core of it because if we
don't believe it can happen then what's
the point
and so yes we absolutely have to take
action but we need the motivation to
take action
i can't say that you know 100 of the
days that i was training i was oh yeah i
can't wait to get out there go training
it's pretty freezing outside it's like
the middle of winter
on the water and the river thames and
it's like ice
um yeah that wasn't appealing every day
luckily the funding came in and we got
to go travel and train in
warmer climates in florida and wherever
else
um but yes there's this
you know goal that's the world
championships it's the olympic games
it's
you know those big dream goals
that are highly motivating but on those
day every single day
i'd be lying if you you know if you
could say that goal in four years time
is what got me out of bed
on that rainy freezing cold you know
january morning
but isn't that the answer then like it
was just take like
do today well yeah so it's
but but also um i do a lot of work
around intrinsic motivation and
understanding what drives us
and and we're all we all have different
drivers
and unsurprisingly one of my drivers is
a sense of achievement
and so my driver wasn't necessarily
on that particular day oh i've got a
train really hard because i want to win
the world championships in two years
time
my driver was probably more that my
coach has set targets every month
that throughout the winter for you know
for five months of the winter we would
have targets every month in the gym
there would be certain
exercises in the gym that we've got to
hit um
we would do tests on we would do time
trials on running in swimming and on the
water
um so as part of our cardiovascular
training so and for me
that was really um i loved hitting those
targets basically that monthly
right so if i do and i know that if i do
this training today
then i'm going to get better and i've
got a test on the weekend and i want to
hit that target i want to
want to smash the target actually
because yeah then there's a good chance
i'm going to win the world championship
it's not just hitting the targets i need
to smash the targets
and so that sense of achievement for me
was a big
driver for other people in my team it
might have been and on actually on other
days it might have been actually
i want to get out and go train because i
want to see my teammates because we have
a laugh and there's banter and it's fun
and i enjoy the connection and the sense
of that being part of a team and the
community and
and all of that and so it's this the
affiliation
that's driving me on some days and but
for others
you know i can think of some of the
girls in my team actually a sense of
recognition
was a big driver so needing that you
know ah today you know you worked really
hard you've
you know you really put everything into
that session you know hearing that from
the coach or
you know look how far you've come or
look what you've you know the progress
you've made or
so everyone and so when a coach can tap
into that
knowing what is it that's going to get
you out of bed today
that's when we start to get the best out
of people or the best out of ourselves
and so
you know when i work with with leaders
it's about what motivates and drives me
intrinsically not just the carrot and
the paste pay slip and the promotion
and you know and and all of that that's
the external stuff which isn't very
sustainable
we need to know what drives us in as
individuals but also what drives our
team
and tap into both of those and start to
ask what what is it that
am i getting that every day and if i'm
not how can i get that from work
what is it that i need to get and also
really interesting you know if you're a
leader of a business and you're working
with a team
are my drivers influencing how i
operate with others in my team you know
so if my driver is a sense of
achievement but your driver is to make a
meaningful contribution
and i'm pushing you guys no we need to
we need to we need to win this and we
need to get the next pitch and
and you're like no i just want to really
help these people
i'm pushing my driver onto you and
that's not working for you
so it's really important to be aware of
what my driver is and know that it's not
the same as yours
chances are yeah that's a good that's a
really good point and i think i've
probably
as someone that probably values a sense
of achievement and
forward motion and progress above all
else at times when i'm trying to
motivate people especially like friends
i'm trying to sell them on the value of
achievement when they're probably just
not asked
about a particular thing i don't need to
win yeah i just want to
doesn't matter to me i i want to fill
ownership of this piece of work
yeah actually that's what's really
important to me and how do you find out
what someone's driver
driver drivers or motivations or
intrinsic motivations are is there
is there a system or like a test or yeah
so i the work um there's some brilliant
work
from um a chat called dean spitzer and
he talks about super motivation and this
idea
that there isn't you know we there's
intrinsic and there's extra extrinsic
motivation so what we use a diagnostic
actually when i work with clients
and it will identify it forces you to to
pick
because you know we all want you know
maybe some recognition or some
achievement or
to feel like we're making a contribution
or to be with people all of this but it
really forces you to identify
what really is your big driver um
so yeah so i use that but i mean i think
when you talk to people you can start to
you know the more you get to know
someone and you ask them questions and
you see the way they operate
and and you see them light up when they
get certain feedback or when they're
doing certain pieces of work
so we can start to get a feel for that
just when we get to know people i
you when you know i asked you there
about the that like discipline and
consistency and what gets you up every
day on like a
rainy tuesday or whatever and it was
interesting that um
you kind of like shortened your horizon
or your skirt like people i think people
typically think they they want to get to
the top of the mountain so they think
okay
um let's make a plan to get to the top
of the mountain but you were so focused
on these like
short-term shorter goals which meant
that
i guess your progress sort of almost
like invisibly compounds
um to get you to the top of the mountain
so instead of like we want to get to
staircase number a thousand we're like
let's get 10 let's do 10 stairs today
and then 10 stairs tomorrow and 10
starts and 10 sets and by the time you
know it
you're at the top of the mountain right
yeah well literally i
i am four years ago i climbed um
mount tubcall of course you did as you
do
and um i
we went with there was probably 10 of us
in the group one of them
one of the girls that was on the group
was a friend of mine and she had i don't
know why she joined the group
but she had a fear of heights oh god um
and we're climbing a mountain and it was
fine for the first day and a half
because it's just like a windy
road the morning of the summit it's
literally
we're going up we feel like we're going
up a steep mountain and you're and
there's boulders
and and she literally
cannot she's so scared of heights and
i can't do i can't do it and eventually
i was like julia you just need to focus
she
what her biggest fear actually was also
getting down
okay um looking down and thinking
how i might get but how the heck am i
going to get back down because
that looks really scary and it's
slippery and
there's there's screen so the ground is
loose and
i'm like don't even think about that
right now
all you need to do is take one step at a
time one
meter at a time that's all i want you to
focus on
and one meter and one meter and one and
we'll figure out the rest and you might
not even get to the top who knows you
might you might not we might start
but just do one meter at a time and then
we'll figure out the down bit
and we'll take it one step at a time on
the way down
because that's all we can do right in
that moment is take one step at a time
and it's the same whether it's a goal to
achieve
you know x turnover in a business or
this many sales or whatever the business
is or
whatever walk of life yes we need to
know the end goal
but actually we just need to focus on
the process
because the summit looks scary but one
meter doesn't look scary
exactly and if you just do one meter at
a time and also you know or
whether it's the fear or oh my god it's
so far away we've got another four hours
to go
it might be you know whatever it is well
actually let's just do the next five
minutes
and let's see if that is feasible
because it probably is right can i do
one
yeah can you take this next step yeah i
can definitely take that next step
okay can you take the next one can i
take the next one
and that feels really feasible you
mentioned earlier
getting at the very beginning of this
conversation getting news i think when
you were about 24 25
that you had an illness called chronic
fatigue syndrome
i'm now going to be incredibly naive and
narrow-minded
when i when you read chronic fatigue
syndrome you think tiredness
that's what you think right but um but i
know it's a lot more crippling than that
and i know that it's a lot more
devastating that especially for an
athlete
um talk me through finding out you had
this this
this disorder but also what it meant for
your career
and how it changed things heal this week
tons of you hundreds of you have tagged
me on instagram and
on linkedin and on facebook as well with
your heel pictures
some of you are trying heal for the
first time and it's so wonderful to see
because as you know i'm a very big
advocate for not only because they
sponsor this podcast but because
i've used fuel for the last three and a
half years to to make myself
nutritionally complete at times when my
career
put a lot of pressure on me to to speak
on stage or to travel
to do business so i'm a huge advocate of
fuel um for you guys watching
this podcast on youtube you'll remember
last week that i said
i was gonna take off my top um and show
you the results
that i've seen for you what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna do two things the first
thing is i'm gonna show you my before
and after
from march until about september time
right so here's my before and after
and also i mentioned in a previous
episode that i've got a friend who's
been a hueligan for the last
i think about the last two years as well
um he was a friend that really struggled
with
food um and had a what one would class
as an eating disorder and he went from
being a little bit
chunky to having six pack abs i'm also
going to take his top off so you guys
can see that
if you're looking at your diet and
seeing that you're a little bit
nutritionally deficient in any way
and you do want to give it a try let me
know how you get on dm me on instagram
tag me on instagram so i can share the
photo but let me know how you get on
i'm gonna tell you a secret for the past
five years while building social change
into a 700 person
global social media powerhouse i've been
using a service that i've never really
mentioned
some of you might know that service it's
called fiverr f-i-v-e-r-r
it's my little secret if i've ever had a
project where i've needed affordable
skilled freelancers to help me whether
it's building a social media application
that made my company three
million pounds or just a video i needed
editing or
help making a logo or making a website
i've used fiverr
now that my secret's out the bag here's
what i'm gonna do for you if there's a
freelance service you need or a project
you need help with a logo
a website a voiceover a video you need
made anything at all
go to fiverr.com ceo i'll put the link
in the description
that's fiverr.com ceo
message me the service you want from the
website and every single week i'll
personally
send you the credit to your fiverr
account so that you can get that project
done
thank you to fiverr for the sponsorship
and for supporting entrepreneurs and
freelancers around the world
i'm looking forward to all of your
messages talk me through
finding out you had this this this
disorder but also
what it meant for your career and
how it changed things so yeah i
like you say was 25 26 when i was
uh diagnosed with chronic fatigue
syndrome and yes
it's more than just fatigue um it's not
just
i'm tired today it's being
devoid of energy exhausted
almost on a permanent basis it also for
me
included muscle pain to the point where
the
my muscles were sorry muscle ache to the
point where it was painful
to the point where i couldn't stand in
the shower and hold my hands up here to
wash my hair
for more than 10 seconds because it was
too painful
um some people have symptoms
i didn't get this so much but sort of
you know like can't concentrate
can't focus brain fog um some people
are actually bedridden um some people
are actually in a wheelchair
um luckily i wasn't as bad as that but i
was
bad to the point where yeah i couldn't
i i couldn't be in my kayak
paddling for more than 10 minutes at a
very light gentle walk type pace
having gone from winning world
championships for two and a half hours
at a very high pace
to can't get my hands to hold my hands
up here i
i was literally two months earlier able
to rattle off 100 press-ups in one go
and then can't hold my hands up here for
more than 10 seconds
so that's the that's the physical
element
and that's only the physical element but
the mental and emotional battle was
just as challenging because
you can't you can't see it so it's not
you know i
i was got frustrated to the point where
i actually wished
that my skin was covered in spots so
that people could see that there was
something wrong with me
and could understand that i was going
through something that i was in pain
that i was
you know unwell but i looked fine
so i got diagnosed with the honest in
2003
beginning of the season it was like
april and then
so following year is coming up to the
olympics 2004
some training for the olympics or
wanting to be training so six months
later
it was only six months later that they
actually diagnosed it because it takes
six months for them to eliminate
everything else and go
oh this is fatigue that's been going on
for more than six months therefore you
have chronic fatigue syndrome
and i re i went off to florida um
and the sports team doctor was saying
right you need to do this graded return
to exercise they think they originally
and they still thought it was
overtraining
that's the immediate assumption right
athletes tired muscle ache
must be over trained um so they diagnose
you
they um offered me this program of
right gently build up your return to
sport um
so you start with 10 minutes at a heart
rate of 115 i can't remember
and then 15 minutes at 115 and then 20
minutes and 30 minutes and when you can
get to 40 minutes then we can go up to
120 heart rate and
so on and so on and so i went out like
my
training group and my coach were all in
florida so i went out to florida to
train and
and i just couldn't get past 20 minutes
um
and so i went out to i went to see a
doctor in florida
and the doctor he ran some blood tests
and
basically like i still looked like an
athlete
i'm still pretty muscly i'm fair i'm
lean
i'm in florida i've got a tan and he
basically looked at me and said
well we've run all the blood tests
there's nothing coming up nothing there
doesn't appear to be anything wrong with
you you look really fit and well
i think you're fine and so that just
this frustration of i can't see it and
therefore there must be nothing wrong
you know it's just mental health right
you know people who are
suffering with depression or anxiety or
whatever it is we can't see it
and so we don't know it and we don't
understand it and so the mental
and emotional battle was really
challenging and um
even people in my sport not
understanding what's wrong with anna oh
she she can't cope with it anymore or
she's too lazy to train or whatever
they're saying all these things and
and that's hard um how did it make you
feel
so in the beginning um
frustrated devastated confused
um sad lonely
so many different things and
frustrated because also we didn't really
know what it was and the doctors are
saying it's overtraining
and actually when i reflect on the
previous two
years i'd had episodes of fatigue
which i now know were episodes of that
same illness but
that only lasted for two weeks or three
weeks or six weeks
and i would stop training or i'd really
cut back on training and then i'd be
able to come
back and i'd be fine again and and so i
only know that it was
i knew in my heart when i went to see
the team doctor that one day and i
remember it
that it wasn't over training because for
six months i had been doing less
training
than everyone else in my group i can't
be overtrained i'm doing less
than everyone else because we were so
conscious of this uh ana's over training
that i wasn't i wasn't it was just was
not over training
and the doctor is like oh you've over
trained jesus
and that i just and then that was it i
didn't train again for 18 months
um and i did i did i after working with
the sport the team doctor i went to
other doctors i tried conventional
medicine i tried alternative therapies
and
and nothing was working and that was the
the hardest part as well was that
one you can't really tell me what's
wrong with me and two you can't tell me
how to deal with this
and and then you know i went to see
one doctor and he said basically there's
no cure
there's no treatment and you're don't
don't don't think you're ever going to
get back in a kayak
you never you might get back in a kite
but you're never going to race at that
highest level you won't race again
so that was that was a pretty big moment
um he said that to you yeah
and how is that to him yeah just
like this is this is my you know this is
my identity this is who i am this is my
life
this is this is my career i still have
ambitions
left to fulfill and i don't
i don't want something like this to end
my career i want to end it on my terms
when i choose that i'm done and so
yeah that summer watching the olympic
games on the telly and athens
um it was devastating and
but i guess i always believed that
i would find a way i was like there has
to be a solution to this there has to be
a way
out um and i i guess that
i'm a very optimistic person and a very
much a
possibility possibilitarian
i call it that i don't know if that's a
word but believing that it's
it's possible yeah that there is a way
out there has to be a way out
and and i guess i didn't know
whether there was but i just had to i
had to believe that there was
i had to believe that i would get out of
this and then i would find a way back
and that i would get back to training
and racing one day otherwise
what what what did i have and not that
my life would be over if i couldn't
paddle
but just that's what that belief i think
is what kept me going
um in that in that time and
and eventually to cut a long story short
i did find a treatment for the illness
and i did recover and i didn't get back
um
but it wasn't an easy journey do they
before we got into what the treatment
was in your recovery
do they know what's happening to you
like physiologically
when you have um that disorder
have they do they know what what's
causing you um
[Music]
the problem is is that there are many
different schools of thought okay
and it depends who you talk to and it
depends which doctor
um and what clinical or study or what
study you read or which one do you
believe
i believe
based on the treatment that i did um
which was a treatment called reverse
therapy and
this was founded by a chap called dr
john eaton
and back quite it was it was only just
um it was quite a new therapy when i did
it back in 2005
for um and
essentially the symptoms are like
alarm bells going off in your body so
these symptoms the pain the fatigue the
exhaustion that can't focus any of the
symptoms that you're experiencing
are alarm bells and your body's way of
telling you
that there are things
going on in your life that your body
doesn't like whether that be pressures
stresses relationships environment
emotions all sorts of things that are
triggering
these symptoms and these alarm bells and
basically if you don't listen
to the alarm bells they'll get louder
and louder and louder
to the point where eventually they just
go right done
you're just not going to move now you're
not going to until you listen
up how how how loud do i need to get
before you're going to listen
and for me it was to the point where i
couldn't train when i can't train i'm
going to listen up
because now it's really bad and now i
need to pay attention
and so um i i'm i'm not particularly
articulate explaining what
the physiologic what's going on
physiologically but that's that's
my interpretation of what how the
symptoms arrive
and how you deal and and then
what i did so that the the treatment
that i did is about identifying what are
those triggers
what are those things that um that your
body and mind are saying i don't like
what were they
and so for me um non-expression of
emotion
is one of the most common triggers and
that certainly was the case for me to
the point where
i didn't open up
to anyone really i have really close
friends i have family i have a sister
i'm really close to and of course i
you know shared it with them but i cried
on my own
for sure but i never cried in front of
anyone else
i didn't really express how bad it was
in fact to the point where people would
ask and you know how are you doing yeah
i'm fine i'm fine
and i would just block it out to them
all the time
and that was just making it worse and
actually when i started to
one of the biggest and most powerful
steps that i took was opening up to
people
to the people closest to me sharing what
i was experiencing with them
allowing them to see my struggle and my
vulnerability
and let them help me that's that was a
big turning point for me
um was being able to just express that
emotion
and share and open up
because par what i was doing was i was
isolating myself
by not sharing it and that was
perpetuating it
um and these emotions are worry or
pressure that you're
experiencing because of the sport or
what were these emotions that you were
suppressing or well so when
not when i was competing or you know
before with the
in the beginning the emotions were
different but in the middle of the
illness like not
just not sharing it with people not
expressing how
hard i'm finding this how um tough this
is that how sad i am how frustrated i am
how
just i can't cope anymore kind of
emotions those emotions i wasn't even
expressing in the middle of the illness
you're being tough yeah i'm being poker
face anna who has learnt to do this
because that's what you do in sport
right isn't that isn't that almost like
there's a bit of a paradox there that
the thing that made you successful was
also the thing that kind of
undid you to some degree it sounds like
well so
that composure and resilience yeah so
when you're on the competitive arena of
sport and you turn up on race day
poker face on game face i'm tough
whether i've missed the last two weeks
because of an injury or for whatever
reason you're never going to know that
because i'm i'm here today and i'm i'm
on fire
and you know i'm ready to race um and
that's brilliant
on the race arena but outside of that
not helpful not helpful in so many ways
in terms of building relationships in
terms of building trust
you know we talk about trust earlier um
you can't build trust and relationships
unless you open up unless you
express vulnerability so true i think
that's one of the reasons i struggle
with my relationships my romantic
relationships is because
i bring the tough guy thing into my into
like my personal life sometimes
and um it doesn't ever help
and i think the the progress i've made
actually in my personal relationships as
you've said
has been by like admitting more that i'm
wrong and like
saying how i feel and being like i you
know what i mean
and that's but that's not conducive with
the whole like
resilient tough guy business thing that
i have to do
i don't i don't think they're mutually
exclusive it doesn't feel like they are
but you're right
like they're definitely not mutually
exclusive but
um they're two different people trying
to achieve two different objectives
in business there's a sense of like you
know you've got to really like stand up
for yourself you've got to be ruthless
to some degree in some
situations especially when you're
dealing with teams and there's [ __ ]
landing on your desk every day and
you're getting horrible horrible news
and you have to put on a brave face for
your team
because you just found out that your
whole server's been hacked and they've
basically
half of them have lost their jobs or the
pandemic has just struck
and then going like
i know what you're saying do you think
of certain moments
i think i'm thinking one particular
moment which i always talk about in this
podcast where on the way to work i got
this news that we've been hacked
and i've got i got 100 or 200 people sat
in the office in front of me
that are now looking through the window
and thinking what's going on and my
my need to be composed and optimistic at
a time when i probably was
panicking a little bit inside i think
got us through
i think if i'd walked out there and been
like listen guys i am [ __ ] it here
it might have but in my personal life
it's very important to have that
intimacy and vulnerability
i think there's um a balance actually
and i think in business
you are if you are able to be a little
bit vulnerable and i'm not saying
vulnerable to the point where you look
really weak but vulnerable
to the point where you're honest and you
might go
do you know what shit's happened and
actually i'm a little bit scared
but we're going to find a way and i
don't know how we're going to
figure this out right now and and it's
not great
and but you know it's about having
confidence in who i am
and what we do and confident in the
people around us
and my team and you lot and all of us
that we're going to figure this out
yeah so there's a balance there between
i'm human
and yes i'm scared like you because this
is [ __ ] and
this is a bad situation that we didn't
want to happen and let's admit that
let's put that on the table and be
honest about it
because people we build trust with
people when we're honest then we show
a little bit of vulnerability and
humanity and
that's how we build relationships
because otherwise we're just putting up
this tough guy front all the time who
doesn't have any feelings right and you
can't relate to that can resonate can't
connect
yeah how do we connect with people
whereas actually
oh you're just a human being who's
scared too and i'm scared and therefore
it's okay to be scared
but actually i'm scared but we're going
to find a way so it's confidence
and we're going to figure this out
because we we are good at what we do
you know our definition when we do our
resilient leader workshops is
a resilient leader's confidence and has
confidence in who they are
and what they do and understands their
areas of strength and their areas of
development
and finds a way to bounce back and
create opportunities
and so if i'm confident in who i am and
what i do
yeah i can admit that i don't know what
to do right now
but i know that i have the skills and
the resources within me
and my people that we're going to figure
this out
i don't know what that way forward is
yet but i know that we're going to find
a way
what if okay so what if you
um and this is me playing devil's
advocate what if you don't
know that you're gonna find a way so say
you're scared
you don't think you're gonna find a way
and you think it's all over
say you've got i don't know 500
employees out there the wait waiting for
you in the middle of the pandemic
to make us make a statement to the team
do you walk out and lie
if you within yourself genuinely as the
ceo of a company
don't you think it's over um
because of i don't know the pandemic has
just happened and the business has
evaporated
when you walk out in front of your team
surely you've got to just lie to their
faces to some degree
like you've got i think that you have to
believe we always
no matter what the situation is we can
only
be truly great at what we do if we
believe without doubt
that the future is bright yeah some
leaders don't
naturally you think of you know just
some people don't so by
like probably probabilistically there's
going to be some leaders that when the
pandemic struck thought we are finished
and that as we said earlier about like
the self-fulfilling mindset will
actually probably take them out of
business
and i just i don't know just because i
don't think i've ever been comfortable
in my career to tell my team that i'm
scared
i've i don't think i've ever actually
been scared because
i am i kind of resist in moments where
i probably should be scared i'm so
focused on solutions
that fear or joy all these other
feelings don't really seem to be
relevant or useful to me
but i don't think i could bring myself
to tell the team i was ever scared when
i was at social media
maybe you don't need to say i'm scared
but it might be that you know what yeah
this is [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i could do that and and
actually right now i don't
i don't know how we're gonna get out of
this
but i do have confidence in my ability
and all of us together as a team that
we're gonna find a way
the leaders have to lie sometimes
i don't i don't i think we need to be
honest i think that
we need to be transparent and the more
we can be transparent and we can be
honest in what we do the better
relationships we build
the better connections the more trust we
have in a team
and we figure it out together i agree
yeah so going back to your i want to
know so what exactly did you do
in terms of you know um daily
to overcome your disorder was it was
there
you addressed you know you started
expressing yourself more was there
anything you you had to take or was
there
you know so there was no medicine there
was no pill there was no
massage treatment there was nothing like
that it purely
is a recognition that the mind and the
body are connected
and therefore i needed to figure out
what these triggers are
one of so to give you a bit of context
so um
i leading up to the sydney 2000 olympic
games
i left the coach that i was working with
that had got me to become a world
champion but i now wanted to go and race
at the olympic games
and he was very much a marathon coach
and
and encouraged me to go find someone who
really specializes in sprint racing
so i ended up for three years having a
coach who was based in another country
and i would go and train with them
sometimes and then i would come back to
the uk
and i would train on my own and he would
send me the training program we'd speak
on the phone
he'd email it to me i'd do the training
and i would basically train
a lot of most days i would turn up to
the training do the training
and i was motivated enough to be able to
push myself really hard to i
had no problem with training on my own
in the sense that i
you know some people can't push
themselves hard and i haven't got the
motivation
to turn up and do that but the problem
with that
was that i and i didn't realize this at
the time
i was isolating myself and
i think i um so i i wasn't engaged there
was my club i was at my club but i would
turn up to my club
and they'd all go off and train
separately and i train on my own and
then i'd often turn up
at times when they weren't there i
wouldn't engage with the british
team really much and i was just ice more
and more isolating myself
and then getting frustrated because i
didn't have a coach she was by my side
and i thought that all i needed to do
was train hard
i thought and the reason i stuck with
this coach was because he was a great
coach and i thought the training program
was brilliant
and i thought all i need to do is follow
a great training program
and work really hard and i thought that
was enough
and actually i didn't i'm not a robot
and i needed
i needed human connection and i needed
emotional support and i needed a place
to vent and i needed to be
able to show frustration and when the
training was hard or when i was
exhausted and i had no one to even talk
to on the riverside bank you know i'm
talking to the ducks
you know it's like i had no outlet for
my emotions i had no
and i didn't even speak up and tell my
coach that i was frustrated that
he sent me the program only two minutes
before i needed to be at the training
you know i was going to train and
because there's this five hour time
difference and
and i just was probably quite unhappy
but didn't realize because i was so
focused on the goal and the end goal and
got to train hard and this is what it
takes
that i was so not in tune with
what was going on emotionally and
i was at my best when i was training in
a group environment
with a coach by my side every day
supporting me
other i'm an extrovert i get my energy
from other people
and there i was spending my days alone
doing this really intense training
program on my own
that is not conducive to a really good
mental and emotional health
and so it was really clear that that was
not
yeah that wasn't sustainable and that
was why i had these periods of
oh yeah three weeks falling apart and
i'd have to stop and
um and then when i'd get back to an
environment that was
i was happy and it was all good and i
would train hard and i'd be amazing and
i have full of energy
and and i and i had my best year and
then i would change and the environment
change and so my environment and the
people around me
and my emotional happiness was some of
the things that i needed to get a grip
on
um it's so fascinating that people
really underestimate the value
of human connection but also the
environment we're operating in
like hugely i've had a conversation with
a friend and he'll be listening to this
podcast because he's never ever missed
one
um he's he was working at my old
company's
um social chain for many years and he's
he's gone freelance and he was talking a
little bit about feeling a bit burnt out
he came to my house he's saying
feel a bit burnt out i'm lacking
motivation in the mornings and things
like that
and when i was a freelancer before i
started the company and had 700 people
around me all day
i just couldn't find the motivation to
like go to my laptop and send the emails
but the minute i was in that environment
where we had this kind of like shared
goal and i had feedback and
community my motivation was higher than
anyone's in the world but i don't think
people appreciate enough
the the importance of the environment
and the community that you're operating
in and
i think there's a certain thing which
people don't talk about which i've
talked about this podcast couple of
weeks ago which was
this idea of like freelance depression
and even like you're seeing it with the
world now from working remotely
having to get up and like now you're
realizing
what your job actually is because before
it could have been like seeing susanna
and hearing about her weekend and
engaging with the office dogs and this
and the sense of community
you've kind of conflated them with your
tasks at work
and now it's just your tasks now you're
waking up and on a computer looking at
your to-do list
and so i think freelance depression and
it's almost what you've described there
is this like
inner lack of fulfillment because you've
lost
what was a huge part of what made this
pleasurable enjoyable but also your so i
guess your support network
yeah um and that's why you know we
talked earlier about motivation and what
gets you off in the morning and
actually going in to hear about susan's
weekend
or you know to see your friends and the
connection and the buzz from the
atmosphere and
and that might be what gets you to work
not the tasks that i've got to do but
actually the people i'm going to hang
out with
and that environment and we need to
understand what is that environment that
we thrive in
and i think people are realizing that
over the last 12 months you know
and especially the extroverts have found
this really hard and if you live on your
own and you're
still and you're not able to go into
work you're a speaker you speak around
the world and stuff and
you you love speaking but the minute it
becomes
just speaking to a laptop over zoom to
100 people you realize that
maybe it wasn't just the speaking that i
enjoyed right yeah yeah yeah exactly i
don't just enjoy hearing my own voice
yeah i enjoy telling my story over and
over again
i i love the connection that i get and
the feedback and the
you know i can't even hear people laugh
at my jokes that i think they're
supposed to be funny
i don't even know if they landed or not
um
and you know when you meet the people
afterwards and you go and engage with
them and how are you going to apply this
and what are you going to put into
action and
and all of that stuff that's that's
that's the energy that i get
when i go and do my work and
that's that's missing right now um and
you're getting it a bit
but not in the same way and so
and i remember actually one of the very
first things i did with my sports
psychologist he got me to do
i think it was like a myers-briggs type
assessment
identifying what kind of personality
type i was and i was a stable extrovert
and and i don't know what he ever really
did with that information
but looking back now that's such useful
information so for someone
if someone had known that and they could
see that i was training every day on my
own without support without people to
feed off
that's where i get my energy of course i
was losing energy and tired
i wasn't getting your body was sending
you a message
i'm like i need people to get energy and
i'm not
surrounded by people that's just one
example of one of the triggers but
you know so it was about finding out
what do i need to thrive
it's fascinating uh we had johanna hari
who wrote the book called lost
connections on this podcast his book is
behind me one of my favorite books of
all time
he's coming back his whole his whole um
book is about the real the nine real
reasons
for anxiety and depression and to kind
of conclude it
in in a very sort of narrow way he talks
about these feelings we get of
loneliness and lack of motivation
and anxiety and depression when you look
at all the studies and he was someone
that was depressed and given the
pills and you know they said oh you're
broken chemical imbalance when you look
at the studies
it's it's almost indisputable that much
of it these days
is because of social factors and our
lack of human connection
they've got examples where they've given
a guy in uruguay
goat who was depressed and because he's
got now that connection with an animal
he's his depression his symptoms of
depression almost evaporated
but the lives we live in 2021
between four white walls if we want food
we press an app
if we want you know to see our parents
it's through a piece of glass and
living alone in these industrialized
cities it's actually completely against
our innate
human programming and he says one of the
things he says which i've written in my
book as well is
about how these feelings are our calling
to get back to being more human it's
like your body calling like loneliness
is this calling
like get back to your tribe you know
what i mean and then
and i and it sounds like [ __ ]
because it's like well my loneliness
isn't the thing
but what you've just described there is
quite literally something that's
happened in your mind
having a real substantial almost
devastating and crippling impact
on your body and health the thought that
your mind
can disable your body is um
terrifying on one hand but also kind of
like a really powerful important
you know but if you think about many
illnesses ailments from
[Music]
getting a you know crafting people will
get a headache when they're stressed
people will get a migraine when at the
end of a stressful period people will
get
sick sick you know so there are so many
illnesses that can be considered
as emotional but manifest
physically yeah it's crazy so it's not
the first example
yeah and and you know like your
loneliness is
my calling to get back it's an alarm
bell right
you're feeling really lonely and it's a
warning sign to you it's a message
to say you need to do something
differently in this example get back to
your tribe
and in the same way that my body the
alarm bells were
i'm going to make you so tired that you
can't train so then you're going to
listen
and you're going to figure out what it
is that you need to do differently to
get back to training
in a really healthy way and when i
returned
back to training i was able to change
lots of things about
my environment about the people i was
with about the pressures i put myself
under
you know all of these things that i'd
figured out and then
i trained harder than i had before
because i was in a really healthy
environment and place
and i was listening to my body and my
mind they call it mind body
and i was able to tune into that and go
every time i was anywhere near just
not feeling quite right i'd go what
what's my my body telling me
right now what is it that's going on
that it doesn't like
what do i need to be aware of and then i
could thrive after that
it's a big shift in conventional
thinking because whenever someone
exhibits
physical illness people say oh what
tablet does this person need
you know what's the chemical and and
that's why you'll get lots of different
if you research
cfs there's so many different schools of
thought oh it's a post-viral fatigue
it's
you know there's lots of um
yeah i guess um physiological
explanations for it
and maybe and there's probably lots of
you know clinical research behind that
suggests that it is i don't know but my
experience was that something else
and that's all i can go by really and
you came back
to the sport competing again i'm
guessing yeah so i returned two years
later and won the world championships
and european championships in 2005 and
then went on to win two more times after
that
and compete in beijing three years later
it's incredible so now all of that's you
know
that part of your career has um ended
very very successfully and you've you
know you reached the real
i mean you were the world champion
multiple times looking forward at your
your
your the career since then and into the
future what matters to you and what's
getting you out of bed now and what's
making you
um excited for yeah
life um i love
helping others now helping others
sharing learning from
my experiences in sport and taking those
lessons
and bringing them to other people mostly
in the business world
and developing people you know
i had you know spent a lifetime
with coaches who were developing me um
or the athletes and the team
and it's the same thing it's about
developing people you know in bus in
sport it was about
getting results through people
developing those people to get results
in sport
and now i'm using that to get results
for people in business
by developing people and and i get a
real
kick out of you know if i'm coaching
someone and coaching a director
or a leader whoever it is i was coaching
this morning
and seeing them have that aha moment
about a limiting belief um
you know getting the new dream job um
engaging with the team being a more
confident leader whatever it is
i love it when i see that change and
that transformation in other people
helping them to change habits to change
behaviors to excel to get the best out
of themselves that's what really
that's what motivates me now is is
helping others to fulfill their
potential
well listen it's been um an incredibly
interesting diverse conversation
one that's made me um have a couple of
my own personal epiphanies so i thank
you so much for coming
today and sharing your story um where do
people find you if they want to get in
touch with you where's the best way to
reach out so annahemings.com
my training consultancy call is called
beyond the barriers so be on the
barrels.uk
i'm on linkedin um we'll find you
they'll finally turn on we can find a
remote yeah
but i thank you so much your story is i
mean it's it's incredibly like
multi-faceted with twists and turns and
um you exhibit you know
so many of the qualities that i think
are
typical with the most successful people
i've ever seen these topics of like
resilience
dealing with pressure and like the
understanding of oneself and your mental
state and
i mean you've got these incredible
twists and turns with with your illness
um so i mean it's just just so
incredibly inspiring and when they when
they suggested that you would join me in
this podcast i thought it was you were
just like the perfect guest for these
reasons
um and you've you know you've you've
blown me away in many occasions and it
made me feel quite emotional as well so
i just wanted to say um thank you for
coming and um i i hope that we can stay
in touch
and um yeah just to thank you more than
anything thank you for inviting me on
the
podcast it's been a pleasure thank you
i've just got one small favor to ask you
if you're listening to this podcast on
youtube or apple or on spotify
do me a huge favor hit the subscribe or
follow button it helps this podcast
tremendously
and in order to reciprocate what i'm
going to do every single podcast episode
is i'm going to pick one subscriber and
i'm going to send you a message on
instagram or facebook or on youtube
wherever you are
and i'm going to say how can i return
the favor and you can tell me what favor
i can do for you so this is a favor
for a favor hit subscribe follow or
subscribe if you're on apple podcast
thank you
[Music]